top gun Maverick all of this
is real these actors trained for
months to pull up to eight G's and
cameras mounted inside of the f-18s
captured real intense flying just look
at the ripples on Jay Alice's face
this shot is different because this
plane doesn't exist it's called The Dark
Star and it uses Hypersonic technology a
tool that's in development by Lockheed
Martin but nowhere near ready to be used
like Tom Cruise's Pete Maverick Mitchell
does this scene is almost entirely
fabricated from Tom Cruise's convincing
sweating and heavy breathing to the
impeccable VFX but the thing that
grounds it for me is the sound design
is why I talked to this guy
I'm Al Nelson my job on top gun Maverick
was to define the soundscape or the film
from Jets to doors
Foley ambiences
motorcycles
and all things Maverick expectations
were high the bar was very high there
wasn't a good enough option it always
needed to be as best as it could be when
Al's team first got the mach 10 sequence
it sounded something like this
a blank slate with one big question
how do you make fake flight feel real
what does the Dark Star sound like first
of all working backwards it's not an
F-18 it's not a fighter jet the Dark
Star is much more elegant it's much more
advanced and one of the things that was
important was for that to be believable
as well it shouldn't sound like a video
game it can't sound sci-fi do you think
of course of Star Wars you know the Tie
fighters are amazing but they're sci-fi
and they used elephants to make them
[Music]
right
so we worked hard lots of field trips to
aircraft carriers cross-country trips
for jet engines and auxiliary power
units we are trying to tell the story of
Maverick's light everything we're
hearing and seeing should feel as real
as it can feel so that we're
experiencing this with him
and Al's job was to make sure that the
experience captured all the intensity of
Maverick pushing the Dark Star to its
limits
it starts with sounds of technology that
we're familiar with so when you see
Maverick launch
he's using turbines we wanted him to
have punch and feel high tech it doesn't
ramp up it just goes and then thrust
Maverick gets up in the air and as he
starts passing new thresholds increase
the Mach 3.5 there's this subtle beep
increased to my 3.5 that starts a
simmering build of tension like Pavlov's
dogs we're being trained to know that
this tone will keep repeating until we
get to the coveted Mach 10. but before
that he has to go faster this time using
technology that most of us don't yet
have a reference for transitioning to
scrabjet
a scramjet uses the speed of the jet to
intake oxygen which ignites the fuel as
opposed to a turbine a turbine can only
spin so fast and can only generate so
much oxygen to ignite a fuel all of that
process needed to be articulated
sonically he kicks it into scramjet and
then you see the turbines closed and you
see the tube open up in the back of the
Dark Star at that point you've got this
flow of air going into the Gen debt
system and igniting that fuel and
creating that rocket
and then
the plane is on its way Maverick starts
getting comfortable
and the soundscape reflects that by
becoming slightly more subdued because
the other thing we're doing specifically
with Darkstar is we are trying to tell
the story of his Joy of being in this
flight and and achieving that which no
one has done before he's the fastest man
alive and so there are moments where
we're just with him as he's smiling the
plain Focus sound design pulls back and
other elements take the Forefront it's a
lot of layers but it's also it's not
necessarily accumulating it's
alternating it's orchestrating you know
when he says talk to me
there's not a lot else going on because
we are with Him emotionally you see the
Dark Star go off in the distance that's
very much a music moment so you don't
need a lot from us at that point and
we're just a DOT and we're just a little
rip as you hear it scan across the sky
so you can track it and then the music
drops out very dramatically and we cut
to him and it's boom and you feel a
little bit of shaking and you hear that
turbine kick on and you feel those
thrusters
instead of having all these clips sound
fade into each other you feel every
single cut
one of my first interactions with Tom is
that the cuts have to hit they have to
punch he was very very emphatic about
that and it's a style that the first Top
Gun established that aggressive cutting
style of cutting from inside and being
just dialogue and rather quiet banging
on to the Exteriors
and it makes the cut feel aggressive it
makes the film feel aggressive and
dangerous and it propels Us in the story
each of these Cuts has a unique Sonic
texture you cut to the rear and it just
bangs on with this ripping tearing
rocket Thruster you see all of those
currents crossing the wings the jet
stream it's such a beautiful Visual and
we wanted to put something in there that
was tonal and special which was the
Roebling suspension bridge
[Music]
so all of these flavors allow it to be
constantly changing and constantly new
and hopefully exciting to ratchet up
that building tension Al's team used a
long time sound design trick the
shepherd tone an auditory illusion where
you Loop a sound wave separated by
octaves which tricks your brain into
thinking that it's a continually Rising
pitch listen to it here in the rising
turbines
so the jet is starting to
complain a little bit and so more tones
are happening and yes that mock 9.7 9.8
each time it's a little bit louder a
little bit higher it's that winding you
up and then the minute he does it
[Applause]
catharsis
but just when you think it's over
we return to quiet and then we start
again with the build
a little push but this time the build is
different it starts with this beep from
inside the control room which plays off
this last beat from the dark star's
cockpit when you listen to them both
next to each other
it's a rising tone and then a falling
tone and this subtly signals that danger
is coming
the shepherd tone kicks in louder and
more grating than before it leaks into
the sound muted cabins so we know that
the pressure is building and it keeps
building until
[Music]
you know it took some hard work to get
us to this final version did some late
nights some long hours I'm very pleased
and excited with with how it's been
received and how it sounds
I know they did design an actual Dark
Star that he sat in you can see him
sitting in it and then at a certain
point it launches over our head and
that's when we get into the magic of
Cinema that was an F-18 that they then
remapped the the Dark Star over it and
that that was so low that when you see
the roof of that shed blow off that was
real that was an unexpected addition and
the fact that Ed Harris just stands
there and takes it
okay he's he's something else
foreign